Mel Kiper draft expert his new drafted
draft was released yesterday available
on ESPN plus we'll get to that in a
moment Mel thanks for joining us if I
redrafted 1984 how do you think the
quarterbacks would Marino or Elway
they'd be still vying for that number
one spot who would you take was 83 83
draft that I think when you look back on
it it would obviously be John Elway I
would still put I thought he was one of
the greatest quarterbacks is all time
once he's certainly directly one those
two Super Bowls at the end after losing
the three to me I think you look at John
Elway with the physical talent and the
gifts he had and then to have all that
pressure on him knowing how great Marino
was right away and John Elway was not I
saw John Elway's a Ruggles struggled
mightily that first year where Marino
did not once he got that starting job at
imagine living in today's era with a
would have been about John Elway with
Marino at the end of the first round
being so good and and phenomenal and
John Elway struggling but then to do
what he did I think was pretty amazing
so I would still put Elway and Marino
and Kelley right in that and that
probably I go Elway Kelly Marina way
Marino Kelly cause Kelly did get to all
those Super Bowls and nearly one one
really total one one very easily and if
that would have happened maybe would
have won more so I would say those three
with Elway won because of winning two
Super Bowls that gives him the edge
stand over everybody else in that dress
if Marino was coming out now I mean
there were rumors why he fell to the end
of the first round because he was he was
NFL ready with just his arm his whole
style his demeanor there why do you
think he fell to the Dolphins at the end
of the first round well I think what
happened there was I remember being at
the Super Bowl that year be that
immobile and uh he was down there Dan
was and you had other quarterbacks who
you know we're really highly rated
keeping my Todd Blackledge when the top
ten that year after the success he had
at Penn State Tony Eason Champaign Tony
what out of Illinois with my quite wet
in the middle of the first round ahead
of Dan Marino has did ken O'Brien out of
Cal Davis went ahead at the a no Moreno
so what happened was I think when people
start getting down for whatever reason
had the
great final year and whenever some
inconsistency is there its expectations
and when you don't see what you think
you're going to see another quarterback
star out there well yeah everybody kind
of gets you know I don't know if they
think it download a player but they're
kind of a little disappointed or they
feel like you've dropped the bits then
rumors as you remember all the rumors
that were going around that year that
all Tomino factors in and then there you
go and then when teams start passing I
don't think that impacts anybody's great
on a player you know you'll see a guy
drop because I want to pass one I'm
being then and go with a guy I have a
lower that doesn't happen but to see I
think for me to see I remember that
going back to that year besides Marino
higher than that but a head of black
legend a head of Davis head of O'Brien
out of Cal Davis I think that was the
shocker once you saw Blackledge go that
high and then you saw ken O'Brien go and
there's Dan Marino still sitting on the
board from Miami that was the amazing
part of it that there was such a gap
between Todd Blackledge at a Penn State
and Dan Marino at a pit and so we're
staying I've know was fired up in that
motivation threat of his career to know
you know what went on that year and that
motivated Aaron Rodgers to remember he
had a sit and and then wait others had
to have had to do that to remember Brett
Favre went the early second round he was
projected to be a 1 so it's happened the
quarterbacks before it and it so happens
that some of these quarterbacks to the
been spectacular you know didn't go as
early as a lot of people thought they
should have after their career was over
if you redrafted the Eli Ben Phillip
Rivers yeah I've still got I said that
if I said if any of those three
quarterbacks or a bus I would say boy I
would've been shocked that I thought all
three were going to be good I think
Eli's two Super Bowls get him in the
Hall of Fame you think about Rivers not
being to a Super Bowl so the Eli would
be a head of rivers Ben would be one if
you had a redress that Ben would be one
yeah what sue Super Bowl wins Ben would
be one I put Eli sue and Phillip three
yeah I'd probably put Phillip Rivers in
their second in Eli third Phillip Rivers
was a really good regular-season
quarterback Eli was not a great
regular-season quarterback Ben has been
a good regular like I if I'm just
looking at the talent that I saw there
you know Ben we just we weren't quite
sure about Ben because he was at Miami
of Ohio
Eli playing at all
miss Philip Rivers at NC State these
aren't you know football powerhouses
there but I think just that Philip
Rivers had a great regular-season it's
just we you know we measure our
quarterbacks by postseason so that's why
Ben and Eli would be it you know higher
than him well I would say certainly the
winning the big games and the money
games and winning Super Bowls and taking
out New England twice I think the fact
that Belichick and Brady two iconic
figures the best in the business best in
the history the game coaching wise and
quarterback wise to take out and
remember ruined that undefeated season
Miami Dolphins wouldn't have had the
greatest season ever had not been
freeline Manning beaten New England so
they were ready to make history so and
you get on that run is he did was not a
great team ever his teams weren't greats
if they say what he wasn't what I was
teams weren't great during the regular
season and he had to go on the road and
win some games against top level
quarterback so I think when you look at
Eli Manning the fact he did it twice I
think that once then I'd have been with
you how to put where Rivers I had to be
live okay but the fact that he did it
twice with New England and Belichick and
Brady I think is the reason why I would
give him the edge Phillip Rivers had
some really good teams and didn't get it
done in the playoffs you can't blame it
all in Phillip but the fact of the
matter is there were some pretty good
teams that even a couple years ago that
team that came to Baltimore in one how
old will mark came on before the quarter
got him back in the game that team
everybody thought had a shot but prior
to the playoffs to be a Super Bowl team
and they didn't get it done so I think
because of that never even being to a
Super Bowl
let alone winning one and he liked
getting to two and winning both against
New England that's the exclamation point
against there was great New England
teams against the team that was ready to
make history over the Dolphins and to
take them out twice I think is the
reason why I would give Eli the slight
edge over Phillip Rivers what do you
think Joe Burroughs game plan is here I
just think right now he's gonna go a lot
of this talked and I said this yesterday
oh throughout the day on ESPN I think a
lot of the talk came from others that
we're bringing it up but like you know
here Carson Palmer drafted number one by
the Bengals you that's deep Bartowski
brought up after being in both the
Atlanta Falcons so it's all been brought
up by others who were in situations that
weren't necessarily the greatest or
whatever when they were coming out of
college or ever however we want to look
at
that but I think the pylon and take
shots at the Bengals is unfair I think
just looking back at their history to
say they've never had quarterbacks that
have had success Kenny Anderson got to a
Super Bowl and lost of the 49ers Boomer
Esiason got to a Super Bowl and lost to
the 49ers when Joe Montana at that great
Drive and in the past the tale or to win
it late in the game when they thought
they had a chance to beat the 49ers look
like they were going to beat the 49ers
you think about Carson Palmer he got
hurt the playoff game he was hit by
Tebow final - so and then you think
about Andy Dalton he had success yeah he
was almost beat the Steelers wasn't his
fault they lost that 18 to 16 game to
the Steelers okay so I think the
quarterbacks that have been there have
had success with Moreau is talking about
leverage he has leverage what leverage
does he have well he's talking about
that after it was all brought up member
initially you were saying that I'll be
happy to be a Bengal he's an Ohio kid
Dan I mean do you really want any
negativity about a city you're going to
and it see an organization are going to
cropping up now if you're going in there
you want to be the toast of the Talon
you're selected but why did you say that
why doesn't he just saying I can't wait
to be a Bengal is mine and those
thoughts are coming from outside sources
what he used to do is step up and say no
I'm gonna fund a Bengal I'm happy I
think he needs to address that at some
point because unless you're planning on
pulling a power play like John Elway did
and like Eli Manning did unless you're
planning to go all the way there's no
in-between here Dan I know you know if
yours are going all the way your end and
I looked out for your either all Bengals
so either all Bengal or you're all out
and say I'm not playing there I want I'm
not gonna so you can't be in the middle
ground because you want to be I said you
want to be the toast of the town they
want you want those fans to celebrate
you coming there and you want them just
for buying your jerseys there's a what
number buy that Jersey okay
so again I think he needs to address
this now and get that over with because
he's going to be a Bengal the way it
looks right now and though I come in
with any negativity like say unless
you're going to do with John Elway did
number he had baseball and keep in mind
- Ernie of course he was ready to get
that deal done the owner traded him
without Ernie's knowledge
Ernie of course he was ready to get that
deal done with John Elway need have been
a Baltimore Colt not a Denver Bronco
so that trade was a steal for the Bronco
was because I needed to make that trade
so again that was a different
circumstance different era then you
think about what happened with Eli well
you had three quarterbacks are all
pretty much interchangeable in that
draft okay Eli Ben and Phillip were all
pretty much interchangeable so charge
was pretty happy to get Phillip Rivers
they weren't I said no Chiefs we got a
guy with a much lower rate right at the
same grade this year you had the
compounds that what complicates matters
as to his injury to uh has three lower
extremity injuries you don't know
durability wise how his career is going
to go okay and then you think about the
third quarterback Justin Herbert
something he's very overrated in the top
ten let alone at the number one spot so
there's not a situation like it was with
Eli Phillip inden this is not that case
burrow had a phenomenal year he is ready
to go and there's nothing really that
he's clean coming in to was not because
of the medical we still don't know what
the medical is going to be on him so
it's not like since I can give up on
burrow and go to plan B that they're
gonna feel phenomenal about right now
because we don't know what the final
medical is on to and as I said there's a
lot of mixed opinion on Justin Herbert
if two is healthy any same sentence in
the discussion to be the number one tech
you can't say the Senate outside will
say topics a will say definitively would
be I'm not ready to do that because I
think that first of all we don't know
how he finished a year we don't know
that that would have been important Dan
how he thanks a day going here with a
matter wasn't able to finish the year
okay you got hurt for the third time the
third time not the first time to ankle
injuries one to the left one to the
right now hip okay we don't know what
the medical is going to end up coming
back with come late April we don't know
what that's going to be so then make
that statement yeah you can make it out
nobody can prove you wrong because
there's a a hat even it's not healthy
it's like saying of Drew Brees was
healthy it had been you know would have
been the Miami Dolphin yes he would have
been in Miami Dolphin
but he wasn't a Miami Dolphin because
there was a shoulder injury question and
Miami passed on him he ended up in New
Orleans so had he not had a shoulder
question history would have been
rewritten Drew Brees would have never
been a Saint Nick Saban probably
would've never coached Alabama because
would had success at Miami with Drew
Brees and history would have been
rewritten there Dan
so I don't think you can answer that
question except to say it's a fantasy
league question that we'll never know
because things worked out in a not a
positive way didn't finish the year
healthy and now we don't know what he's
going to be moving forward hopefully if
you're optimistic because I try to be
and you think everything's going to be
positive
he's gonna be a guy as I said all day
yesterday the teams I think will want to
trade ahead of Miami to get that would
be the Chargers at six could be Carolina
could drop down a little further down to
the Raiders in the Annapolis Colts they
could be looking to move up there which
would force Miami at five B and if all
the medical is positive and we hope it
is one two that would force Miami still
up from five to four make a deal with
the judge ago for as I projected five
the three with the Detroit Lions that
would force them to do that because if
they said it five they could lose to it
is somebody else you're in midseason
form already great to talk to you Mel
thanks for joining us we appreciate your
time as all hyper Mel hyper I think we
got to change his name to Mel hyper Drac
draft expert his latest mock draft
released yesterday available on ESPN
plus four more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]